hi Bethany how are you I'm good how are
you days better than I deserve what's up
in your world well my husband died we
think we know what we want to do now is
just secondary advice because we are
some of the Mulligan owners that have
fallen into the emissions problem
scandal whatever you want to call it and
we just found out this week that they
are going to be offering a buyback
option on the affected models and then
it also includes a cash payout or you
can keep the car and get a higher cash
payout than what you would if they
bought it back and we've done some
numbers and we could either take this
payout of paying off the car and maybe
making about five thousand after and
like trying to get a used car but we
have a second we have a third car that
four hundred miles away where my husband
works he works out of town he goes on a
train for two days the money comes home
he doesn't need it there and so our shot
is do we take this money pay offers our
secondary car loan and then bring a home
this other car and we've figured we
could be debt-free in a year from the
buyback and are you like do we really
need that other car and is that the best
choices - only four miles away what is
it worth and the car it's only worth
like $2,500 and what is the Volkswagen
Worth and right now it's worth fifteen
thousand but it's only your and a half
old three water's
owed on it twenty eight twenty eight
thousand is owed on it yes the buyback
will pay for the value before the
emissions scandal so twenty eight how
much is the value somewhere between 26
and 30 it depends on the model and
whatnot you have to like go and file
with Volkswagen and then at the end of
the month when the courts rule in favor
of this program you laughter your
registration is done they'll say okay
your model gets this much money and the
option of price you have the option of
accepting it at that pole
you don't have to accept it blind
correct when you go in and go in and do
that right there now going you you
submit that anyway just to see what
happens okay okay and then on top of
buying the car for 26 to 30 that you owe
28 on they're going to give you more
money yes they will give you a cash
payout to say hey we're sorry yes we
already did get a small payout for how
much more it will be roughly about forty
two to five thousand it's a percentage
based on the value of the car okay and
if you don't do the buy out roughly what
will the cash buyout bit pay out and for
my model I looked at it and it's about
seventy two hundred dollars which go if
we put it on the car we still owe 20
grand I understand I understand yeah
yeah and so you're desperately upside
down in this car because of the
emissions scandal what are the mounts to
so because of that really no other
reason you take this deal out because
here's the thing you have a twenty eight
thousand dollar debt against a $15,000
car that you can sell for 26 or 28 or
$30,000 you sell the car okay and even
if you turn around and bought another
one you sell the car follow me and but
but cause because there gets rid of this
dad and it's not just the debt but about
you yeah yeah okay it um yet you have
somebody just walked up and offered you
twenty eight thousand or twenty six
thousand dollars for a fifteen thousand
dollar car whether you're in debt or not
you would get that you would take that
yeah that's true and so you take it okay
that that's the way you analyze it and
then you take the five thousand and then
okay so now we hopefully you have
nothing you get enough out of that offer
the twenty eight to pay the twenty-eight
and the five goes in your pocket and you
bring the twenty five hundred dollar car
home and drive it and you put the five
on your other debts maybe how much other
debt do you have and well we the twenty
five hundred dollar car is paid off we
have a five thousand dollar truck loan
that was
in which I shall trade also good and
that would pay us and then we have
$4,000 credit card and a about eighteen
thousand nineteen thousand student loans
on me and okay well we would pay off the
credit cards first because they're the
smallest yes and then we pay the rest on
the truck and so you got truck and
student loans left and your household
income is what it's in the nineties
awesome okay yeah that's exactly what I
would do and let me just tell you let's
just think this through one more time
this has nothing to do with baby step
two it has nothing to do where you are
in the process it has nothing to do is
is this car too nice for you with your
income it's none of that it's simply you
have a fifteen thousand dollar asset
that someone just offered you thirty
thousand for one hundred percent of the
time unless you are unless it's a family
heirloom
you take that it's not I have a I have a
seventeen thousand dollar car that's a
1979 Corvette sitting in my garage if
you offer me thirty four thousand
dollars for it it's sold yes follow me I
can see that yeah that's the way you
look at it and the rest of the stuff is
just your story that's wrapped around
this mess well but you're not having to
do this because of where you are you're
doing it because it's the deal of the
century it's the deal that would get us
out of debt in one year but it not no no
no no it's the deal of the century and
it happens to also help you do your
story yeah okay
I mean it's just you sell a third you
sell a fifteen thousand our car for
thirty thousand every time you can in
any situation that's the issue so yeah
you're right on track do it do it do it
do it do it wow I didn't know that was
that big a deal I knew they were doing
buyouts of stuff but I've been
Volkswagens gonna get hammer that must
be a billion dollars or something or
more I gotta look that up that's amazing
scary wild stuff hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
so you have to break the cycle you have
to flip this thing on its head and make
it behave you've got to get so fired up
and wired up that you're broke friends
think you've lost your mind